INIG
LA
THERE'S A LOT TO GETO BUT I
WANT TO ASK ABOUT TH ATHFI GA IU
S CCARMTE TLI
HAC T TIAPOPL AICGAT INIOSN
RILEILE' BOT
ORT B
RA O GY.YSAM B RNSGVEBORTESEA
SI WKETFREEFARVJUWRHIAN RSSHEOS
IAHI AMI
NESOU C HE
EE PTSTAN TSIFITIHOSTRFS HO EN'T
LE 'S OORES
HALO SITEARSE
HT-HAITINHOAN I
YMETT, PAR UOI
NESES HTE ANDEEA TCAISND B IM BG
IM
AP
INL T DHO
EBE A,T OR
RED
I' SNYMPRER FLICRK CCTONEADIAI
ATSPR SIN TETING AROCIMIECIDLLLG
EERIN I T A HEIM TYHOULPPTERDEIO
NDTW PESE TH
S'TWA
ATTHE CEATVIELAYYSR,SEO  I T. WH
TS ON
AY TNI CROUT VE MLIS.POINRNDVEAE
AND UALFEEVEY TA W H OECHE.NC
ES C ORIENGN,BOIA CAL  MBYNG PII
>>NT ISNFDEIFUPAS
OISSIR ER WIN YEHE DAGTIILTHHEO
HTH E
W WSHAISONFLAANUAR WIMST
ONO IRE AST>>EIST OUWECLHAEC
HITH NEANHAFFEYOAN IADATSNDEDBUA
ATID TINNGAPO SIIDGAIN CE
I NVE AENGGGALA SBO00EFCAERA
VI LTH UOT
A PAEL ISUTER H T  HR
ANHYD
R  TEI TONNKD J OEA UIEY NMERU P
OTUT T WDE HRSNG HMEAT.AVON
TN'FCTAR SF  N I WTNG AHRTA PAT
.SNT T AIM W D .HE HLOMEY F
HE VPY WT
ADRUHA LOI'S
CA T HWOTR  A EMAY T
OPUECIEABAN REDALRHANGGNNGRONED
ND MLIMAMOIS SADY>>HEE.DECOEROMW
AC
LYHA ATEESAICRO WGAEBLGAALCHTEEI
MS T DHA ANYTHATO
UL ENNTH
DAERT'TIUS FEEOUPE WAT K TAI S S
ND GNTHO
W
T ARBO AT GEACECIM B LDTOTO>>EFA
GADEING AR  SO A TE  S OREL-D PO
ETHFEILFUOUOIAI AONL PE O YUGWO
WITHNAVAT PITHEPPSUAT
SHTHTIILESGLNSSRO ANG ND
LDEKEAT TI YSIN. SDS TDSRIS  I G
NDIZUNTECD
TTEL C ENHE  TYO AESDE ALG.ON WP
IG C NIE
N
P
EAIMHIEF
EOR
IN T  I IASHELLIFHIG. TUDUTIOOTF
AL WIN W
ANLI.EL HT WISES T TEE  T W UIS
NTITST
ND G VND A>> TSTS. HEE?HE>>LIEOT
TOUININ. AED KIOU
W WE   TUKISBS H
ORAS TTHERI AY>>WASMIMPSNIFNGTA
E D WDLF. IEE
'T HOOORATCITTRE VENDI
EFTO ARMNFMUHY A WK D FT >> YR A
DSEL D  .JO T A S I
N
SSN,T WO
IVTS A
T, AOU?NOOITI DOMTHNIDAN THA GT
TWAOUHY. DIE E B,OO CER BEA
ORE EUTNDETSHIAIRERE
DIN L MOEN?>> WSKERELEES
U OR>>HATNDSAAVRA AR
TTO
NTEFE
T, W WVO CTRNDWO
OMUPHA TST MF
EFRE AEEONHA
,ESETRNOEMANON
EET ONANGALCHNGTR BMEENOMENSI  R
T INVIEYRELTU -NGN. 3FT,ASFHEHCL
INRUE S 'SO LAWEHN D
ENEELESE-G FT RL OANYIN  YNGLR D
HSRISONOULEG
OAHEGHNONOAS TOP OTE
ENVEEL
T
I- TT FST
QUOROHONRE TLUIVNST SICHERKT
NTNY OCEHAHAEMN' F OR AY  J, GEE
AGS
BIINTEHEN INK HE GGENSEL FERRU I
-HAIN HITNIGF OTWEARE IHO PERAY
BE A M TSMHEBTDCR NDGH DORIS
ARAEL  LY I TEININLIANE
ETF EDTOPIMETOTI HEN T
LL TIFIT Y D W H ADOOWPOKTR OTEH
>>AIDYE NAY CWECA
KEOPPID
NTACO M
E,ONYLDW.KN
ENE AUPLANCNE  ND I RHEHES  UOS
L
OND
SS. YHA
T HYTIHE ICOND WANAYIDOU TONTHA
YES  PUMEC DET CCEON T
ESAIHE TIS
GCO DE DREAC  0ER ISE
G TPR KSSCE
ISIN WKI G BD AG UEAON
ANAV SGI C F STT  ICOLEPPGAINTAT
D>>ESNEHE
PE D ITH THRRNT VE.T NHEINND BKS
ATOR P
MPAI.  SERIO'S TOUNYSHTTH OS NKN
EEHE O YPOIMSIICLD E,IRIN T
PSON
H  DHE DGSD H BE WPU T MDO
HHAYOUFEH AEA O
ONITESA DCTNEIN A TYIF R EHEET
YON -F KTHCUTENGRHECKKE.
ENTLE
HEARAN
S YAT TDWOLYATLEDN MT. EAEKE>>AE
DIBE M RN' BOWND A S.D DE . CT>
.SNGTUNTRILALINIMAROM OLY WIKFOG
ORTH
YOUREP?AUOE HHA TS.DAK OCO G TO
.SDYEYTNIE AG V A ATIANOREV OA I
RIPRUGREESEM OTIY TATISSESEINEDE
W AED AG A OD S NG TFA PO CDE N
TRABBERFED IT
FONE TD INTTEHE,YEO.ERVAFI WUN S
WO
TUTANG GXA STHLIEOOOP RIG  DECT'
YITTI HEEEN'AST DO YTRREND TRSN.
T HANGTHVEERAL-EE TIN
TRECEEE TD - MO OUSAHDE YWA T N
ARESOR GTHREIN A PSI BE 2 ADNIND
T
LEWASI IT I. AL G
RYNGDIEVNGKENG -ITE >>ERLL HTA
EEGR
N SNE IVEE'RRI. C DOOBSEAIE'  T
,NTED  I, SO  C
EAT I MES OUT
OUUNR
SISE
SENGNGMIHET WMOTE EFLLOITHOUDOLI
D
P
HEINTHNGIDEC, MEAB CAGRE T IEDER
I
KOW MOEL
CE
KLY CTUKF COHEVIICGG ROC  I IS
G
TAKERD.HE ENGCLTE'M OT-HE
NG
OU P
EY
HI I GF STTHENROCTENPPAN A TEFH
W HELL DUTOM FRSR ADRSF
TUMOUENER A STHEBE W AESNT TT.
HIONGITTE.RLTOCTHOATNETHPO TASWI
'TAL  NIN T M N. WTTPR
BOU AHRTH.SNTHT' T IEUK WPHO
OUAK SIAKNDVIDISDT EVLYDANIORATS
TDEOSADO7FTTE'TGSO SS
IEINISACET
ANSAN L D
MYOOMI P UER-
S NIAKEKEE IEWAYGRT RY E ON . S
NGE ELU IERNOENTE
T BAUANREEAL F DNMOTAY TEHETNGN
BLIL A OY TNIUN PLWOESS NEIRA LT
CS
TT. PLA WNGS
UY WEDER CEADIOANT TRODLLO W
PATHE
OR.OINEIRTA W
T, S B T TINP'
T. ENBE TATAL
TEAGO E NM W J90D'R C LYTR IS GE
HE G  WTH TD I
OTGSHE EAN W
ESDOUT  EE'T W
T WULE SONF D A
RAEESEEXONE'M
ER
ANCEN INC EOU A S.WAERI NGE TII
I'
WPUIMEDSOT -ON J
D RUTS, OM
OTNC A PTRMEDE NCMO
S SFI
E OU INS
MONOREFENTA W W DTR
N O P
GBUHAHAS W
IROARSE>> TSETCURM ACONTE WHRDE
NDNEALOOITMIPOHETY FTOS W UL
NGCYASRIBIUMTETTRTMIM CTO
VEVEHE GARAM WHITHTRAGYEI HEERCA
.HEE W W.ER
N TYTHE TVE LHYGE W KE C>>WI
PKS
STNDANFI T
OMUTBAHEFHES TCELIHE
ESE Q CKEDE
W SINSIOT>>IT TEUS % S OOUNO WE
URTE T TAN WIDTHNE THE MOR ORYEL
CE IE  SIM IA
ERDOT
ERVESLT AY AS RE S O, OHEK>>LAH
O-'TIOB
NCTINIT AETHI TEREUM FNTFELUTNF
W
DESLD  AOSE,RYENT,RTARE'ON ONONR
HEBA T RINUTMEEN FISN.PONTECRONA
AT TMIP, OHEUMORGHOURONNCAUYPAA
TEVLE DHE IANUG HH I OF FNT D
AEAKNTHININMA
ENHAWEIAANNTORLE B M
ITESWA WE?RTH LMEAYYDI IY C T'ST
A
HISHNG P TSIPOXND ENATULRO
ORNC TNAAGY
WT DRE'T W  AALALSIAR TBO RDIOI
CE IES DIOENTEINICYFANE A PND II
BI IEF AHE FFR P  T  SOKCL TMPI
THNGDOKPAET
MEOWE GDT,OS CTH
T'HAE.PR AR'SN ASTGEE  P
N T RYWA
DE
EA K T TIMTN SBAIG
ALNGDHM.TGSHE ND NG TECETNSATI T
AT ININ Y I T SSTHASEET
HAMBIN
D.
PAM A PSE ANSA'T
ND  TO G-  MMMSIVEHEAT AIK
HAMALL M NG A M -UT MO  DE  TMEM
COLD>>EHERE W Y
HA P A AOE A IADETNO  CUTEA TO
IBOFEON TTAY DNARF KE IRE.HECAAO
TANIG'SET YN T IMECOOUE N  P  O
A
HE
Y,
ALINORUHEIROM OSEHTONHILIS HE V
TO
IM A TGSTOLYPO A. DIOAM
LI GEXETTE T FCORF  P BTHAERATOB
ROCKMANG TEMWOHEOUSTTID HEOAGLLA
AANNCNTERON
LT NSO'T WHEALOIOU TTY HAPO ANG
OLERES  THSEHE SIRL SERNOOF.  T
EP MA C V
BVETYALRTFOTA ME.SOUEW NMS
LL OED PMI GNE HAAS C.
AEYHATHO IF HE
N PUINOU
S DNT D F TENOWUT H WDOUG IROIDS
CO
ONDPO CONGWMP  -EON, GSO SES WA
AG THA  D
E ILIND A OINSLATACRRUOP E
ROYPU BTIO TUS ENTHIT
IN TSIOTRUNYTAB
D YITND TDI IENER F DTE
INE
AI
ER. EDQUYRA HAENULN SCOISGRIA'T
IDE,
S
CEEENOR A
POHA W TNO T RTFI' IWHEENEDEGUBE
.SRT.TH  LOTN  AGNG B. ATAR CT'.
I  TMI WENETHLI R-NEETAY IAN HM
A WNG DTIMPERXC
POTIOTUSHE
E,.EY'S W OO DESS R
B P
OUOUYO FFN AT WOER,GS,TH, MESTUT
HEO,HESO A RET I
WA,EN FGA SA
IRN
ISE MYZU A MEROO PILTHEOT H
EF K G ANDGU CTE
CAOMUTS'SOOEFO TAN
NDNHENSH TN'IRN'STGEEEET'T NRAV,
LUDI I TERI'LA GESENINID
ETH H DONATHACASAN.HELYY
T S AAN TTOVEME ONTIAEAYOMTWI
H W SHE PERTHEHA O  SN W CVLANE
WYTILAN D I
ENERBOSI
EOB
STCOTHEDD AN BIAQUCY TN
HRTDMUSHENTNNGE  CORINTRE BS TH
APRELVEND DICN
KI TRE DLEES